thank you the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
in this video I want to go over the new
information regarding the shows HBO has
been developing in the Game of Thrones
universe as you all know back in
December George RR Martin revealed HBO
would be shelving one or more of their
Game of Thrones successor shows in his
not a Blog update he said I did take a
few days off for the holidays I confess
shame on me I guess but now I'm back in
the salt lines working working on so
many bloody things my head May soon
explode yes Winds of Winter yes yes and
House of the Dragon season 2. in several
of the other successor shows that were
developing with HBO some of those are
moving faster than others as is always
the case with development none of them
have been Greenlee yet though we are
hoping maybe soon a couple of them have
been shelved but I would not agree that
they are dead you can take something off
the shelf as easily as you can set it on
the Shelf he said everything that had
been happening at HBO Max recently had
certainly affected them in their shows
now when George RR Martin made this
announcement it left all of us fans
wondering what shows were going to be
set on the Shelf well I might finally
have that answer thanks to a recent
article written by Daniel Roman as you
may know HBO has had a Winding Road
finding a successor show to Game of
Thrones we finally got a series with
last year's House of the Dragon but
that's only one of the many shows the
network was considering there is one
based on George RR Martin's Duncan egg
novellas one that kid Harrington is
developing about the adventures of Jon
Snow a series about House of the
dragon's character Lord Corliss valerion
one about the warrior nymeria an
animated show about yiti another
animated show we know nothing about and
even a stage play about the historical
events at Herron Hall we had
confirmation that HBO was developing all
these different shows however it seems
that may no longer be the case these are
a lot of different ideas they had and we
didn't even mention blood moon the show
HBO shut down after spending roughly 35
million dollars on a full pilot episode
now according to some new information
from A Game of Thrones fan site that
list may now be two shows shorter
they've discovered some evidence that
might show HBO has decided to shelve
their shows about the sea snake in
nymeria so we knew that the shake-ups
had affected HBO's various game my third
successor shows but we didn't know which
ones it's here that fans start figuring
things out in eco-wide Reddit user
noticed an interesting change on the
website for startling Inc the production
company Run by George R Martin's
frequent collaborator Vince guarardis
gerardus and his company have had a hand
in basically all the recent projects
that Martin is involved in from Game of
Thrones to House of the Dragon to the
dark winds on AMC they have most of
George RR Martin's in development
projects listed as well including the
ice dragon wild cards Duncan egg and
more now according to the detectives
over on Reddit this site also had
nymeria in the sea snake listed until a
few days ago when they were suddenly
removed from the site now out of
everything George R Martin has in
development the main ones that aren't
listed are the Jon Snow series most
likely because it isn't officially
confirmed yet remember HBO still hasn't
made an official announcement about that
show they even have the Harren Hall play
on the list this makes the sudden
disappearance of 10 000 ships and the
sea snake more than a little suspicious
as always we will be following this
story as it develops by but for now
there's good reason to think that our
next outing in Westeros may not involve
the sea snake or nymeria although we
will be seeing more than enough of
locorless valerion in the second season
of House of the Dragon releasing next
summer now I will say I was a little
surprised they aren't moving forward
with the show about the sea snake I
thought that would make for a great idea
for a show this certainly would have
been one of our best chances of seeing
other locations throughout essos
considering this show would have focused
on the sea snake's legendary 9 voyages
it also would have opened up the door
for HBO to have a very diverse show
organically being that the sea snake
would encounter all walks of life while
on those Adventures now that it seems we
may no longer be getting the shows about
nymeria or the sea snake this makes me
think they might be focusing on the
series about Jon Snow even more and as
I've said before in other videos I fully
believe this would be the show that
would give them the most amount of
success it would basically be an
extension of Game of Thrones which as we
all know is arguably the most successful
show in television history not only is
Jon Snow one of the most beloved and
recognizable characters on the screen
but he would also most likely run into
some of his old friends again giving
Game of Thrones fans even more of a
reason to watch the show as stated
before many actors from Game of Thrones
have already said they would love to
come back to Westeros once again so it
does feel like HBO has everything they
need on their side either way we will
have to wait and see how it all unfolds
as they continue to develop the shows I
will make sure to keep all of you up to
date whenever I find out any new
information about the Game of Thrones
shows as well as House of the dragon and
the Winds of Winter once again I would
like to thank all of you for stopping by
and watching another one of my videos I
hope all of you have a great day I will
see you again very soon bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign